it's the biggest state election in india
uttar pradesh in the north is home to
more than 200 million people and is
voting in seven phases
you can see how prizes are rising modi
said he'll bring good days and
prosperity yes best days are here with
prices of vegetables touching the sky i
have voted thinking about inflation
uttar pradesh sends the highest number
of members to parliament and is seen as
reflecting the national political mood
prime minister narendra modi is halfway
through his current term these polls are
regarded as a test of his bharti janta
party's policies
sugarcane fields like these cover large
areas of western uttar pradesh millions
of lives and votes depend on it
amit kumar's family has owned land here
for several generations it was once a
lucrative business now costs have surged
and farmers have been waiting months for
sugar mills to pay them
our earnings have been badly hit what
can we do we have to pay our children's
school fee you see those laborers
working if we don't get paid on time we
either have to delay their payments or
pay them less
many farmers here took part in a
year-long protest against three
agriculture laws they said favored big
corporations
last september they hosted the largest
of those protests in the state targeting
the bjp ahead of the polls in 2017 the
bjp won a landslide victory in uttar
pradesh but growing economic distress
among farmers has diluted some of that
euphoria last year the modi government
revoked the three agriculture laws but
many farmers have continued to protest
saying that demands have not been met
experts say this has bolstered
opposition parties making the bjp seem
less formidable in the last 2017
election the western u.p built up a
momentum in favor of the bjp but this
time it seems that
you know the fortunes are going to smile
on the opposition more
and if they continue to build up the
same kind of momentum that we saw in the
first round of voting then we can say
that will be anybody's game
polls are also being held in four more
states results will be declared on march
10 and will indicate how the bjp may
perform in the next national elections
al jazeera uttar pradesh northern india